you're so famous that your dog waka yeah  has his own Instagram he does  yes he has a what's happening to this  country I know I mean I'm happy for your  dog thank you but I mean it's it's it's  well he could give a crap about having  his own Instagram account so yeah really  for my ugly hat yes exactly  we have stills of him here this is him  how do I get a ride at a moment with the  Austin Cooper he's whispering look at  look at the bicep done the Silver Fox  yes he's weight Anderson Cooper's this  Silver Fox  yes that's his nickname that's super fun  yeah hello we're here in Beirut I'm the  Silver Fox  yes and then what is it what was going  on in this one right here Graham there  he's snapping that's his good buddy  there in Brooklyn and his caretaker  Sherman's house he's just having to say  that might be a post-coital  he looks like he has regrets like I did  what he you learned that from his daddy  [Laughter]  you